we needn't have come so far as Guardian  death would have come to you soon enough  now by your hand your universe was never  meant to be your world and your family  will be excellent running out of time  there I'm sure this is going to work  these devices were made to detect a no  it's not costing  you know with all that power I thought  should head harder  the converges would be in full effect in  seven minutes that just means we have to  keep Malekith visit for ache  okay you might want to hold on to  something  well gravitational fields interact with  the weak spots between worlds creating  out there waving his arm around and  everything  [Music]  you